Speaker 1: The January 6th House Committee.
Investigating the Trump riots isn't going to last
much longer. And the reason is that the House is
being taken over by Republicans in January because
Republicans won the 2022 midterms in the House.
See how I say that without any qualifications?
See how I just say Democrats won the Senate but
Republicans won the House. I don't have to rant
and rave and say because of rigging or because of
fraud or fraud, or because of seasoned ballots or
smoked ballots or sauteed or CEU voided ballots.
Just Republicans won the House and Democrats won
the Senate. See how easy it is for me to say that.
Okay, because that's what happened in November.
And and really, anyway, because Congress is ending
and any investigative committees would have to be
reconstituted in the next Congress, the January
6th committee of the House is going to end, but
it is not yet over. They told us some months ago
that they would come back with a couple of final
hearings sometime before the end of the year. I
don't know if that's still going to take place,
but yesterday there was a very important bit of
news that was announced. The House January six
committee has decided to make criminal referrals.
Let me remind you. So we're all on the same page.
One of the guidelines of House committees
remember the House of Representatives. The
House of Representatives has investigative
duties and responsibilities and abilities.
They do not have primary criminal referral
responsibility, meaning the House is not
supposed to take on an investigation primarily or
solely to determine whether criminal activity took
place. However, it is well within the purview of
the House of Representatives investigative duties
to make criminal referrals. If in investigating
whatever they are investigating, they come across
what they believe to be based on the advice
of the lawyers that work with them. Criminal
activity. That is exactly what the House
committee says it found. CNN reports the
House Select Committee investigating the January
six, 2021 attack on the U.S. Capitol has decided
to make criminal referrals to the Department of
Justice. According to Congressman Bennie Thompson,
Thompson's a mississippi Democrat and said
the committee has not yet narrowed down the
universe of individuals who may be referred. Of
course, that's code for we've not yet ruled out
a criminal referral against the failed former
president Donald Trump. Asked whether Thompson
believed any of the witnesses perjured themselves,
he said, quote, That's part of the discussion.
When the panel makes referrals, Thompson said it
will be a separate document from the panel's final
report that will be sent to the DOJ. A select
committee spokesperson confirmed to CNN that
criminal referrals will be considered as a final
part of the panel's work. The spokesperson said,
quote, The committee has determined that referrals
to outside entities should be considered as a
final part of its work. The committee will make
decisions about specifics in the days ahead.
A source tells CNN the criminal referrals the
January six committee will ultimately be making
will be focused on the main organizers and
leaders of the attack. So one of the major
obvious pressing questions is, is Trump seen in
this particular context by this committee based on
the work they've done as one of the main leaders
and organizers of the attack? And if so, is there
going to be a criminal referral directly to Donald
Trump? Now, it's important to remind people.
I have no interest in aggrandizing or minimizing
what may or may not take place here. The question,
of course, if the DOJ receives a criminal referral
from the House of Representatives for Trump
is whether they actually decide to charge him.
There's no guarantee just because a criminal
referral is made that Trump is actually going
to be charged perjury. Also, if indeed it took
place by those who did testify, if there are
if perjury took place, it would be nice to see
perjury charges, which are very difficult to
prove. But we just don't know about that. Many
people writing to me and saying, David, do you
know if the referrals will be made public or
will it be behind the scenes? My understanding
from looking at this article and others is that
it will be a separate document that will contain
the referrals, but it will be made public that the
evidence is public, the testimony has been public
and the referrals will also be made public. Now
I want this all to move quickly. We all do.
It's been years with a lot of this stuff at
the same time. It makes sense that the January six
committee has taken a measured approach. They've
calculated it. They've done everything by the
book. There was strategy and it shows. And this
really was carried out in a way that despite and
in the context of massive Republican obstruction,
because, remember, there was initially a deal to
have significantly more Republican representation
on this committee, and Republicans refused to
participate because they wanted the committee
to focus on different things. They had all sorts
of rules that they wanted, which made no sense.
So ultimately, the committee was assembled with
a few Republicans Adam Kinzinger, Liz Cheney.
Is that all now? AT No, I don't remember. But
in any case, it was by their own doing that.
This was the format of the committee. Now we
have a time limit. There's a new House led by
Republicans which will be sworn in within a
few weeks. This is the end of the committee,
but it may only be the beginning of the criminal
part as far as the DOJ is concerned. Next step,
let's see what the referrals show and then
go from there. We will have all of today's
stories and the clips and feedback and more on the
Facebook page. Make sure you have liked the David
Pakman show on Facebook at Facebook.com. Slash
slash is important and that's a forward slash,
not a backslash. David Pakman show.
Quick break and be right back.